[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and welcome
to episode number 167
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I'm Mark Mandel.
And I'm here with my colleague,
the wonderful Gabi Ferreira.
How are you doing today, Gabi?
GABI FERREIRA: Good--
I like the wonderful.
How are you?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
doing pretty well.
Who do we have joining us today?
GABI FERREIRA: We have,
today, Emma Haruka Iwao.
She will be talking a
bit about the number pi.
MARK MANDEL: If you've seen
any of the news recently,
it's gone everywhere,
which is awesome.
So Emma's going
to talk about how
she broke the world record for
pi, which is pretty amazing.
GABI FERREIRA: After
we finish with Emma,
I'm going to be asking Mark
the question of the week--
how do I track what is
happening to my containers?
Who has access to them?--
changes, and so on and so on?
MARK MANDEL: But like
always, why don't we
start with our Cool
Things of the Week.
GABI FERREIRA: Let's go.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah--
I'm going to go first.
GABI FERREIRA: OK,
you can go first.
MARK MANDEL: So the first
cool thing of the week--
the website has gone
live for Next On Air.
So as probably many of you
know, the flagship event
for Google Cloud, Cloud
Next, is coming up.
But if you're unable to
attend in San Francisco,
there is a livestream that
you can watch, Next on Air.
It's actually pretty cool.
The website slide will
have it in the show notes.
But it has multiple channels.
There's a live stream, so
you can see the exhibitions.
You can see
particular breakouts.
There'll be exclusive content,
customized programming--
all sorts of good stuff.
Probably also worth noting is
that, if you're interested,
you could also organize
a Next Extended event.
So if you want to bring your
local community together--
and basically, you get to go
watch the livestream together
and do awesome things.
Read the guide.
Have a look at "Becoming a
Host," and all the details
therein.
There already are a few set up.
So you can also
check out the map
that shows you where Next
Extended events are happening.
So if you want to check those
out or attend any of them,
you can see which
ones are local.
So make sure to check out that.
I think, it's going
to be really cool,
if you aren't going to
be there in-person, here
in San Francisco.
GABI FERREIRA: But
another cool thing
is, if you are going to be
there in San Francisco for Next,
you can get Cloud certified.
And we are going to be
making available six cloud
certified exams to be
taken at Next, on-site.
So there is a link
on the blog to see
what you need to know to
be able to do the exam.
MARK MANDEL:
Fantastic-- we're going
to do a shout-out to our
friends over at Google Maps.
They're pushing out a
few new releases with--
well, GDC will be
right now actually.
But they're adding
some new features.
So if you wanted to
have gameplay data that
was based on, say, Google
Maps pathfinding and routing
algorithms, you'll have
access to that now.
They also have
interesting information
about biome data-- so basically,
what kind of environment
you're in, like a desert or
grassland or things like that.
They're also exposing elevation
information as well-- so
whether you can go up and
down, the height of where
you are-- that kind of stuff.
So if you want to
learn more, we'll
put a link in the show notes.
But if you're going to
be at Game Developers
Conference, which is
literally right now,
make sure to come
to the Google booth
and check it out and talk
to all the people there.
GABI FERREIRA: Now, a trip
to memory lane and nostalgia
from the '90s.
MARK MANDEL: Oh!
I'm so excited.
You have a mission--
Google Earth just released
a game within the app,
where you can try to
catch Carmen Sandiego.
And you go around the world
to find the jewelry that
was stolen by Carmen.
[SIREN WAILING]
GABI FERREIRA: So this is
actually the first game.
And it's going to be
a series of games.
So you just need to
keep an eye for it--
literally, an eye for it.
MARK MANDEL: I'm so excited.
I need to play this very badly.
This is literally my childhood.
GABI FERREIRA: You
just said your age.
MARK MANDEL: That's, OK.
I don't mind.
Well, I tell you what-- why
don't we go chat to Emma
and hear about all the amazing
things she's doing with pi.
GABI FERREIRA: Let's go.
Let's go talk to Emma.
I'm very impressed.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do it.
So it is an exquisite
pleasure to have
Emma Haruka Iwao
joining us today,
fellow developer advocate.
How are you doing, Emma?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
I'm doing good.
Thank you for having me today.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, thanks
for coming to join us
in the podcast booth.
We're going to talk
about Pi Day today.
But before we do that,
why don't you tell us
a little bit about who you are.
And what you do here at Google?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Sure,
I'm a developer advocate
with the Google Cloud
Platform-- so on the same team
as Gabi and Mark.
I was working in
Tokyo until December.
And I just moved to Seattle.
So I'm one of you.
GABI FERREIRA: Welcome.
MARK MANDEL: Welcome.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Thank you.
My work is usually around
computing products like
[INAUDIBLE] machines,
storage, network--
these all subtle products
and technologies--
not like containers, machine
learning or everything
you think of when you
hear the word "cloud."
GABI FERREIRA: So
Emma, what is pi?
Tell us, what is pi?-- for the
layman or lay-woman in this
podcast.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Sure-- pi
is the constant of the ratio--
so I can read this--
a circle's circumference
to its diameter.
So usually, you use 3.141--
and it goes on like this.
You probably learned it--
MARK MANDEL: How many numbers
of pi can you remember?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: So I can
do it in Japanese better.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
It's usually four.
GABI FERREIRA: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: OK-- it's
more than I can remember.
I got, like, 3.14.
And that's it.
Then I'm done.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Yeah--
3.14.
That's a usual
approximation-- yes.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, that's
what calculators are for.
So what would I use pi for?
What's its application?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: It's
everywhere, right?
So whenever you see a circle
on your computer, they use pi.
And if you want to play a game--
and usually, you have some kind
of UI, part of those circles--
when you launch a
rocket, they use pi
to calculate their trajectory.
It's everywhere.
GABI FERREIRA: So Emma,
how do you calculate pi?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
Good question--
I used y-cruncher.
That's a program developed
by Alexander Yee.
So I just designed a
cluster on Google Cloud,
run the program for four months.
And here, I got the results.
MARK MANDEL: Did
you just say you--
GABI FERREIRA: You
designed a cluster?
[LAUGHTER]
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Yeah--
yes.
The amount of data didn't
fit on a single machine.
So I had to use 25 machines.
[BELL CHIMES]
And it takes a little
time-- like, four months.
[BELL CHIMING]
GABI FERREIRA: Wow.
MARK MANDEL: Four months?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: How many numbers
of pi did you calculate for?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
31 trillion digits--
[BELL CHIMING]
--and a little bit.
[BELL CHIMES]
So it goes, like,
three 1s, four 1s-- so
exactly like the sequence of pi.
GABI FERREIRA: Oh, that's neat.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: 31 trillion
digits and [INAUDIBLE]..
MARK MANDEL: So step
us through this.
There's a particular
algorithm that you
use for calculating pi.
And there was an existing
program for that?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Yes, exactly.
MARK MANDEL: OK-- cool.
And then you distributed that
across multiple machines?
Is that right?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
Not technically-- so
that program doesn't work
in a distributed manner.
And pi is fundamentally
difficult to--
for power of computing,
it doesn't work well.
And so here's a problem.
On Google Cloud platform,
you cannot attach up to 64
terabytes of storage to
a single virtual machine.
MARK MANDEL: Right.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: And
in order to calculate
31 trillion digits of pi, you'd
need more than 170 terabytes
of disk.
And to mount that
amount of storage,
I had to run 24 storage nodes
and attach them remotely,
through network.
So I had to use 25 machines.
GABI FERREIRA: So
you used 24 machines.
But how did you get from
one digit to another?
It's not made to
work distributed.
How did you get to link
one thing to another?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Sure-- so the
computation-- the main program
runs only one of the machines.
And the other machines
were just storage.
They are literally disks--
NFS.
So you just mount these
disks on the main node.
And you just store the
data on the other nodes.
So the calculation--
the algorithm itself--
wasn't distributed at all.
And we use iSCSI instead of
the regular NFS protocol.
Because iSCSI also is
better for random access.
And we needed lower
latency, more bandwidth,
for a lot of random
reads and writes.
MARK MANDEL: So you
made 31.4 trillion--
and a little bit apparently--
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
And a little bit.
MARK MANDEL: And a little bit.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
And a little bit.
MARK MANDEL: Why that number?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: The
previous world record
was around 22
trillion digits, and I
wanted to make it significant.
I could do, like,
23 trillion digits.
But it'll be like,
oh, you just did
it to break the world record.
And I want to make
it similar to pi--
like, a meaningful limit, by
making the sequence exactly
the same as pi.
Pi goes on, like, 314--
so the actual number
of digits goes,
like, 31.4 trillion digits.
MARK MANDEL: Is this all of pi?
[BUZZER BUZZING]
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: No,
pi continues infinitely,
so you'd never get
the entire digits.
It's an irrational number.
There is no end.
GABI FERREIRA: So why
did you do that, Emma?
Why did you decide to
break the world record?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
Because it sounded cool--
[LAUGHTER]
--of course.
MARK MANDEL: That's
a good reason.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Yeah--
I have a long story here.
Basically, when I was a
kid-- like 11-years-old--
I learned about pi and
soccer in school, probably.
And at that time, I had
access to some [INAUDIBLE]----
[DIAL-UP BUZZING NOISE]
--not the internet--
before the internet.
And I was able to download
a program to calculate pi,
so I could do something
on the computer
that I learned at school.
So it was cool.
And I wanted to actually
calculate more digits.
So the program had the text
about the current world record.
And it was, I think, billions
of digits or something.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: And I wanted
to calculate more digits,
but I couldn't.
I was terrible at math.
I had no idea how these
algorithms worked,
so I had to wait.
MARK MANDEL: Until
you got to Google.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Yeah--
basically.
And I didn't have enough
computing resources either.
I had no access
to supercomputers,
because I was an ordinary kid.
And I just started calculating--
22 divided by 7 is a
good approximation of pi.
But it took a while to
realize, it was not actually
true value of pi.
My math teacher told
me the approximation.
And I wrote a program.
That's one of my first
programs I wrote in C.
And I was cheated.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: How much disk space
did you end up actually using,
when you calculated pi to
3.4 plus a little bit--
I'm just going to keep saying
that-- trillion digits?
How much space did you
actually end up using up?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: So for
the temporary work space,
it used about 170 terabytes.
And to store the digits,
you'd need about 30 terabytes,
because each digit is a byte.
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
that makes sense.
And is this data set
available to use?
Can other people play with it?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Yes, sure.
So we have the digits
available via HTTP.
So you can actually
download the digits
entirely from Google Cloud or--
it takes a little
time-- like weeks--
to download the digits.
And if you just want
to play with it,
you can launch a virtual
machine on Google Cloud
and copy snapshots
of the digits.
I'll put that link
somewhere in the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: We'll put
it in the show notes.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
So it's really easy.
We have snapshots of
the disks' images.
You just need to copy it.
It takes, usually, 10 minutes
to copy the digit-- like,
30 terabytes of data.
And we make the digits as a
disk for your virtual machines.
And you just need to mount
it for your virtual machine.
If you're running
Linux, you just
need to run the Mount command.
If you're running Windows, you
need to open the control panel
and mount it.
MARK MANDEL: So you said
that it took four months
to calculate it all.
How much did that actually cost?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
That's a good question.
I don't know precisely.
[LAUGHTER]
Because I used the
Google Cloud Project--
shared with other people.
So I don't have access
to the exact number.
But I did some math.
And it's around $200,000.
MARK MANDEL: That's fine.
GABI FERREIRA: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It's fine.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: It's fine.
GABI FERREIRA: That's cheap.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
It is not cheap.
If you build a computer--
like buying parts
from hardware stores
and eBay and stuff,
you could probably
build a computer
that can calculate to
31 trillion digits of pi
in 4 months for tens
of thousand dollars.
So if you build a computer,
it'll be a much, much cheaper.
GABI FERREIRA: Yeah,
but it's a trade-off.
MARK MANDEL: But where
would the fun in that be.
GABI FERREIRA: It's a trade-off.
It's on the cloud.
So you have redundancy.
You have all that kind of stuff.
So it's just not the storage.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Exactly--
so if you run this calculation
on your physical computer,
you'd have to take
care of disk failures,
because hard drives break.
[WHIZZING NOISE]
Even SSDs break.
So you'd probably need to
replace disks a couple of times
during your calculation.
If your disk fails, you
need to stop the calculation
and replace the disk and
restart the calculation
from a checkpoint.
You'll lose some time for that.
And backups and
restoring is much harder
on physical hardware.
Because if you're running
the program on cloud,
you just need to take
snapshots of your disks.
So that's easy.
You even don't have
to stop your program.
But with physical hardware--
because hard drives
is not designed
for simultaneous I/Os--
you need to stop the program,
copy the data to other disks,
and restart the program.
So it's much harder
on physical hardware.
MARK MANDEL: I
was going to ask--
did you actually have any
failures during the four
months?
Or did it just keep running?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: From
hardware standpoint,
we had no host failures
or interruptions.
But during the
early experiments,
when there was live migration--
because on Google Cloud, when
there's something like
maintenance or software
upgrades on the host side, we
live migrate virtual machines
to another host.
And live migrations usually
takes tens of milliseconds,
if you're running a web
application on that.
But for a pi calculation, it
takes as long as 15 minutes.
MARK MANDEL: Whoa!
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: So that brings
your [INAUDIBLE] this way.
The program starts to
copy memory regions
and disk to a new host.
And it usually doesn't
impact your calculation.
And then when the program thinks
they copied most of the memory
regions-- because
you never catch up--
it stops the virtual
machine, copies
the rest of the memory regions.
And we started computing
on the new node.
But pi program works in
a way that it literally
rewrites every memory
on the virtual machine.
So memory bandwidth is
faster than network bandwidth
in most environments.
So the live migration
program never catches up
with memory copies.
So it needs to stop
a little bit longer--
like, usually 1 minute.
And then it restarts
the calculation.
But it still needs to
copy the rest of memory
from the older machine
to the new machine.
So that slows down the
calculation for 15 minutes.
Because we used iSCSI
to mount remote disks.
There is a time-add
value for iSCSI.
And the default value is around
10 seconds to 15 seconds.
That's usually enough
on any network switch.
But we had to increase
the value to 15 minutes.
MARK MANDEL: Got it.
But once you increased
the value, it was fine.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Yes--
and there was small softwares--
large-scale computing
is hard, because--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah!
I was going to say,
stuff breaks-- like--
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Stuff breaks.
And usually, memory
disks are protected
by checksums or ECCs or
some kind of error detection
and correction mechanisms.
But we read and wrote
around 10 petabytes of data
over the four months.
And there were two
occasions that the data
was cropped silently.
And y-crunch, the program,
detected the corruption.
MARK MANDEL: Oh no.
GABI FERREIRA: Well, good
that the program detected it.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So in that
case, can the y-cruncher
pick up where it left off?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Or do you
have to start all--
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
Oh, no, no, no, no.
It--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, that's good.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Yeah.
GABI FERREIRA: I
have a curiosity.
It doesn't a double write?--
like, one to save the disk
and one to a saving point?
Or how does it work?-- like,
it has saving points every 100
digits or something like that?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Sure--
so y-cruncher saves checkpoints.
So checkpoints are internal
structure of its work memory.
So it flushes its internal
structure to the disk
occasionally-- maybe twice
a day or once a week,
depending on the progress
of a calculation.
And pi is calculating
in a way that you
need to store,
actually, all the digits
you're working on at any
point over the calculation.
It doesn't work-- like,
you calculate the first 400
digits and then store data
and continue the next 100
digits or something like that.
You need to decide
how many digits
are you going to calculate
before you begin and move on.
MARK MANDEL: You mentioned how
much disk space you were using.
How much memory was in there?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: So I
used one of the biggest
virtual machines, with
1.4 terabytes of memory.
MARK MANDEL: And
how much of that
did you actually end up
using?-- like, a lot of it?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: A lot of it--
99% of that.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: I
just left 20 gigabytes
or something for extra--
just in case.
GABI FERREIRA: And
how many cores?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: 96 cores--
vCPUs.
It's on the Dion
Skylake processor.
So there were a couple
of virtual machines
I could choose from.
One is the n1-megamem-94.
That's the machine I used, with
Skylake processor, 96 cores,
1.4 terabytes of memory.
The other choice
was n1-ultramem-160
with 4 terabytes of memory
and, like, 160 cores.
GABI FERREIRA: Wow.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: But it uses
broadware processor of Intel.
And it doesn't support AVX-512,
which would significantly
speed up the calculation.
And y-cruncher doesn't
work very well with NUMA.
The NUMA is an
architecture where
you have multiple
memories attached
to each of the processors.
So they have non-uniform
access calculating
latency and bandwidth to
each region of the memory.
So the more cores you have,
the more complex and slower
the memory access will be.
So actually, adding more
cores might have slowed down
the calculation.
So I decided to go with
the 2-socket system,
with AVX-512 support.
AVX-512 is an accelerated
instructions by Intel.
So it processes 512 bits
of data in one clock.
So it's much faster than
the regular floating point
operations.
GABI FERREIRA: I never
thought actually changing
the number of course
would actually make
the access to memory slower.
That's a interesting
best case to show up
how that can influence
proportionately
inversed situation.
That's totally cool.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Yeah--
totally.
It's counterintuitive, isn't it?
So for large-scale computing
or mathematical simulations,
memory bandwidth is one
of the important factors
to determine hardware
and algorithms.
And recent computers
are really constrained
by memory bandwidth.
So you can't actually feed a CPU
with enough data that you need.
So CPUs are much,
much faster usually--
more than 10 times faster
than the main memory.
And storage is much
slower than memory.
So in order to
keep CPUs busy, you
need to design memory
architecture and memory access
patterns carefully.
MARK MANDEL: That's
really interesting.
What was, probably, the
most surprising realization
you had when you were
building this stuff?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: It was
much harder than I thought.
So in the first place, before
actually doing that project,
I thought it'd be--
not easy, but not too hard.
Because you have cloud.
Everything is redundant and
protected by different layers
of software.
So usually, you don't have
to worry about single disk
failures or anything like that.
So I thought, I wouldn't
have to stop the calculation
or I wouldn't have to worry
about disk failures-- anything
like that.
But there was live migrations.
And it did affect calculations.
And mounting 64
terabytes of storage
requires some design
and [INAUDIBLE] errors.
And y-cruncher has some
tunable parameters.
So you can control
the disk I/O size--
like block size of disk I/Os.
For hard drives, you
don't want to write data
by a small chunk--
like, 4 kilobytes or something.
You usually want to write
in blocks of megabytes.
But I used SSD for the project.
SSDs are much better with random
access and a similar access.
So I had to run some benchmark
to determine the best block
sites for disk access.
GABI FERREIRA: Thank you.
So I remember, when
I was in school
and I had to calculate
the exponential.
And that was hard, because I
could only do it for so long,
because of the
memory allocation--
that kind of stuff.
So doing math in
a regular computer
is really hard,
because you don't
have enough resources to do so.
What the common
person should look
for if they want to try to
do more advanced math?-- like
you did.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Sure.
So there is a website.
It's called Wolfram Alpha.
That's a free web service.
There is a pro subscription.
You probably want to pay for it.
But with Wolfram
Alpha, you only need
to enter any algorithm
or equation formulas
and Wolfram Alpha will
solve that equation for you.
So you can render
graphs and plot
charts, access certifications
on Wolfram Alpha.
It's really convenient.
I usually use it to start
with any new equations
or mathematical programs.
So usually, when you use
a calculator or computer,
you only get approximations.
If you put 1/3--
1 divided by 3-- you'd never
get the true value of 1
divided by 3.
But with Wolfram Alpha, it
treats the rational number
as it is.
So you usually get the
true value of a formula.
So that's really convenient.
If you want to play
more with math,
y-cruncher has a feature
called Custom Constants.
So you actually
enter the formula
you want to calculation.
And y-cruncher handles the rest.
So you can calculate--
for example--
1 divided by square root
of something-- something
like that-- with y-cruncher.
And somewhere in
between, we have
Colaboratory, which is a hosted
version of Jupyter Notebook.
Jupyter Notebook
is a Python program
that you can interactively run
Python or any other programs.
So there are a couple
of services where
you can use Jupyter Notebook.
Cargo is one of them.
Colaboratory is one of them.
So you just need to log in.
You can try different math
problems or machine learning
problems.
So it's really easy.
Yeah-- I use it all the time.
MARK MANDEL: Before
we finish up,
Emma, is there anything
you want to make
sure you get on the podcast?
Or anything cool that you're
up to in the near future
that you want people to
come say hi to you at?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
So we are planning
a talk on this project at
Next 19 in San Francisco.
That's in April.
I don't think we
have free tickets.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: I don't think
we have free tickets-- no.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: I don't
think we have free tickets.
But if you happen to be at Next
19, please come to our talk.
We'll invite Alexander
Yee, the actually developer
of y-cruncher.
GABI FERREIRA: Oh!
MARK MANDEL: Oh-- cool!
EMMA HARUKA IWAO:
Yeah-- at Next.
So it's going to be exciting.
His program was used to
break the world record
five times before our record.
So it's really a
popular program.
GABI FERREIRA:
Mark, I'm probably
going to leave you at the booth
and go straight to Emma's talk.
MARK MANDEL: That seems fair.
That's reasonable.
I don't blame you.
That seems totally fair.
Well, Emma, thank you so
much for joining us today
on the podcast and talking
to us all about pi and math
and doing really crazy
stuff on the cloud.
GABI FERREIRA: Thank you, Emma.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Thank
you so much for having me.
GABI FERREIRA: So
thank you, Emma,
for coming and talking to us.
And now, we're going to ask Mark
the question of the week again.
So how do I track what is
happening to my containers,
and who has access to
them-- changes, et cetera?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah-- that's
a really good question.
If people aren't
aware-- on Google Cloud,
there is a thing called
Cloud Audit Logging.
Cloud Audit Logging is
essentially set up to answer
that question of who did
what, where, and when.
And that's a thing.
And part of Cloud
Audit Logging is
being able to do audit logging
on your containers as well.
So by default, container
analysis-- audit logging
is set up for admin activity--
so basically, anything an admin
would do to any of
your containers.
But for example-- container
analysis rights and things like
that-- and reads--
are not necessarily
set up by default.
But you can set those up.
So if you're go into
your Cloud Console
and you go into Configuring
Data Access Logs,
you're able to configure
exactly what it
is that you want to track
with your audit logs,
regarding your containers--
maybe other audit logs as well.
So you can see exactly what's
going on inside your system,
if you want to track
certain security things
or maybe just see what's
actually happening or maybe
even debug a problem.
So super, super handy
thing-- so if you ever
need to see who
does what, where,
and when to your containers,
you are able to do so.
GABI FERREIRA: So George Orwell.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent--
before we finish up--
Gabi, what are you up to?
What are you doing?
GABI FERREIRA: I'm
doing a lot of stuff.
I am going to be
on Cloud Next 2019.
That's going to be awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
GABI FERREIRA: I'll
be doing Pi Texas
right after that-- on the
weekend after Cloud Next.
And before all of that,
I'm doing a webinar
on migrating to Cloud SQL
on the Google website.
The link is on the blog.
MARK MANDEL: Nice-- awesome.
So when this comes out, it will
be Wednesday at Game Developers
Conference, at which
point, actually,
the Google booth will be open.
I will probably be floating
through there a lot.
I will be presenting at the
conference on Wednesday.
I'll be doing a booth talk,
talking about open source
in game development--
I want to say--
Thursday afternoon.
Check the booth for details.
I'll be floating around
doing all sorts of--
Game Developers
Conference is huge.
I'll also be at Cloud Next,
as Gabi will be as well,
doing podcast-y stuff and
giving a talk on Agones
and all the other good things.
I'll be at East Coast Game
Conference in Raleigh, North
Carolina shortly thereafter,
talking about Agones
and, again, open source.
GABI FERREIRA: That's awesome.
MARK MANDEL: And
then finally, I'm
also going to be at I/O
doing some fun stuff as well.
So if you're going
to be at I/O, make
sure to come and say hello.
GABI FERREIRA: Not even
I go to I/O. I'm jealous.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I haven't
been to I/O in a while,
actually.
I'm pretty excited.
GABI FERREIRA: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome--
well, yeah, Gabi.
Thank you so much for joining
me on the podcast this week.
GABI FERREIRA: Thank you, Mark.
Have a nice week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah-- and
thank you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]